well exactly one year ago tonight
BuzzFeed released the Trump dossier to
the public even though they couldn't
verify any of its content some of which
were scandalous and salacious we blasted
for him at the time now they're getting
sued president Trump's attorney Michael
Cohen has sued both BuzzFeed and dossier
creator Fusion GPS the oppo firm saying
the document defamed the president by
baselessly linking him to russia
conspiracy theories BuzzFeed
editor-in-chief Ben Smith came on the
show to defend the dossiers release a
year ago and is game enough to join us
once again Ben thanks for coming up
thank you for having me on Tucker so
you've been sued by the president's
lawyer what's your response well I think
it's very much what I told you this time
last year the dossier itself is that is
a document of kind of obvious central
public importance it's the subject of
multiple investigations by intelligence
agencies by Congress that was clear a
year ago it's actually a lot clearer now
that before you know before we that
before we published it as we knew then
important elected officials intelligence
agencies were investigating this
document when we talked last time that
was a subject of some dispute and a lot
of people I'm not sure if you said this
but a lot of people on the right said
you know this is an irrelevant nonsense
document now what I see on Fox News in
particular is that this document was
central arguably to central to the FBI
investigation I think that's clearly
established now yeah I think you're
right I mean you're absolutely right it
was central it looks that means they
sent we know and there's a lot we don't
know about its role in this
investigation but it sure seems like
that's right but then you've been doing
this for a long time and you know that
all kinds of in effect dossiers come
across the desks of investigators and
Intel agencies law enforcement agencies
in politicians and people cover them and
they're not made public because their
contents are unverified sometimes
unverifiable and they're defamatory and
so you know you see a lot of stuff that
you don't pass on because you don't know
if it's true and the words hang in the
air you libel someone in effect so you
don't run it but you did run this
because it was Trump your inbox and mine
as you say are full of all sorts of
would-be dossiers of tips
of claims they are not full of documents
that are being briefed to the President
of the United States to the
president-elect of the United States
being fought over in an intense tug of
war by intelligence officials that you
know for instance imagine covering the
week that we just had right imagine
covering the Simpsons testimony to the
Intelligence Committee the battle
between Feinstein and Grassley in a
situation which you were not allowed to
in which you had no idea what they were
fighting about I mean I just think that
it's hari that Americans would have a
lot of trouble understanding right but
you're making a retroactive argument I
mean I guess this was know that it was a
piece of dark matter that was pulling
the FBI that was pulling Harry Reid but
it's important to understand what they
do wait that's the point is that we now
have the context for it and we didn't
then we obviously knew that a lot of
allah it wasn't actually we didn't read
it on BuzzFeed I didn't know this was
part of a Hillary Clinton Oppo operation
that she took up from a Republican anti
Trump Republican donor operation we
didn't know the extent to which steal
apparently had gotten some of this
information from Russian intelligence
and shady Russian sources there's a lot
we didn't know I'm in the description
the characterizations of steel' sources
are actually in the dossier but the you
but it's true there's been a ton of
subsequent reporting so Vegas here's the
point so you're arguing okay it's at the
center of the news so we were right a
year ago to run it and I'm actually not
even attacking you for running it I
would just like you to acknowledge that
partisanship played a role
so procedure that is just not true we
were in the exact same situation with a
president Hillary Clinton we would have
run that dossier at the same time I
can't prove that to you but yeah we
would for instance for instance there
was a day last year the day last year it
was a it was not the biggest story of
the day because they because it was the
day of the Access Hollywood tape but
also on that day we were the first to
report on the substance of Hillary
Clinton's speeches of her secret
speeches you know I mean I think that
there's this speeches to like Goldman or
something but that's not look this is
different levels she was interested in
the once they came out but I mean they
were pretty Eisen
I was I was interested but but they
weren't claiming that she was into some
weird sex practice with me I'm not sure
you are
this is obviously very unusual now what
we have actually all that we have there
was a lot of stuff floating around about
Obama in his personal life and and of
course the you know question where he
was born his birth certificate and we
sort of laugh about it now it was a big
news story and people were making
allegations about including now
president Trump if you came across a
dossier in the middle of the Obama
administration that laid out in some
detail he was born in Kenya and had a
weird personal you would never run that
because he's being taken seriously by
the intelligence agencies if he was
being briefed to the president
absolutely if it was a Republican
president if look if Trump were
president at them is off again we all
recover I mean Donald Trump made these
ridiculous claims about the birth
certificate and we covered them we
didn't bleep them out okay but if there
was a detailed dossier on the subject
that have been assembled by the
political enemies unfortunately the
dossier was his may he was he was smart
enough to put all that stuff in a
dossier that he published and sold it
his memoir as his memoir in Obama's case
for the photo look the truth is this
stuff was unverified a year ago it
remains unverified I hope you will
elements some elements of it actually
have been corroborated okay but the big
stir the big stuff has not been there's
still no way I think the payments to man
afford which and in the metaphor did I
admit are pretty big approving and the
big raise with the Russian government or
that he's with with hookers in a hotel
or I mean that was a central character
assassination and it's still unproven I
mean that is that is unproven the the
broad outline of a Russian campaign to
penetrate and influence the American
election I think it has been established
yeah well it's been going on for a
hundred years Ben thank you thanks for
having me Tucker